- Men who shave their faces
either go full beard or nothing,
because the stubble hurts my thighs.
(upbeat music)
- We are shaving our faces and
I'm really excited about it.
- Why are you excited?
- One, I heard it helps you apply makeup.
- I think I'm gonna do terrible.
- Many women shave their faces, okay?
There's no shame, some
of us have mustaches.
- Guys, don't even look.
- I've shaved my eyebrows before
when I couldn't get to the salon.
- Your eyebrows?
- Wow, that is an arch.
- That's precision.
- I'm really impressed that guys can do it
and not cut the crap out
of their faces everyday.
- If I don't cut myself,
then I'll be really proud.
- Cuz there's contours
that are happening here,
and I can barely do my ankles.
- So let's go do it, everyone get up,
(clapping) let's go.
- All right.
- I'm fixin' a shave my face.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Whoa!
Oh my god, I don't wanna use
the ones made for women ever again.
- Karl, are you scared when you do this?
Do guys do this quickly?
Just get over here.
All right, well first of all
how much do you use, generally?
- All right, more than that.
- Whoo, it feels weird on my face.
- [Quinta] Oh my god.
- I wanna stressed that
we are shaving our faces
for the first time, but plenty
of women shave their faces.
- It smells like a boy.
I like wanna make out with myself,
I love this scent so much.
- This looks awesome.
- What a good lather Quinta.
- You just look like an
adorable santa claus.
- I messed up, it's in my nostril,
I can't breathe. (laughing)
- Go up or down, up or down?
- Okay, aah!
(whispering) Whoa!
- There is hair coming off.
- You're going so fast.
- Well isn't there pride
in the time limit?
- What do I do, I do this face, right?
(garbled speech)
- So I feel like I'm about to grow back
a full beard.
- [Becky] You're not going to.
Guys it's not gonna grow back thicker,
Google it.
- Oh, we're going into mustache territory.
(measured breathing)
- I like this part.
- [Karl] The neck is the hardest part.
- I'm not shavin' my neck.
- That hurt, that's very dangerous.
- Ooo, actually this is kind of erotic,
oh my god.
- [Voiceover] Slow down Becky.
- You're so close to your veins.
- Do you enjoy doing this,
cause this feels really good.
- I'm glad. Do I enjoy this?
Oh my god, this feels really good.
No, I hate it.
- That was scary, that was
like dangerous territory.
- Aaaaw.
- I could go toe to toe
with a baby, right now.
- Look at that lack of mustache.
- Your skin's like really shiny.
- Yeah, you look different.
- Overall, I'd say a little underwhelming.
- My face feels amazing.
It feels like so smooth.
I feel like it looks more radiant.
- I can't believe men just shave up here.
I felt like that was a little
bit too close to my eye.
- I feel like the same
girl, but a different man.
- Every time we do stuff like this,
it makes me respect men a
little bit more, not gonna lie.
Gabby's gonna hate me, but it does.
- I would for sure do this again.
The girls say it looks radiant,
Karl, say it looks radiant.
- It does feel nice afterwards.
- [Becky] Right?
- Soothing is (beep)
- It's a good way to like wake up.
I should bring a razor to work
and like do it after lunch or something.
- I'm gonna use this from
now on to shave my mustache.
- My face feels good.
- I like was really into
myself for a moment.
- I thought I was making
out with myself on my neck,
like if you don't have a man to do that,
you can just be sensual
like with yourself.
It's a little scary.
- I'm also proud that I didn't cut myself,
so hey what's up Dad? I'm an adult.
- I thought it was fantastic.
- I'm gonna go kiss some people tonight.
I'm gonna be like "Oh my god!"
- In movies there are
scenes of like powerful men,
like shaving.
- Yeah.
- Which is funny, you don't
see powerful women in movies,
like making plans while
they like shave their legs.
- [Quinta] Well maybe we should.
- [Becky] (laughing) Maybe we should.
- [Quinta] Yeah.